in den letzten jahren hat ein thema die
jugend ganz besonders beschäftigt
designermode und auch auf youtube war es
durch wie viel ist ein outfit wert
ladies pickups und andere formate immer
wieder ein wichtiger bestandteil der
unterhaltung aber können wir uns diesen
hype zu nutze machen und daraus profit
schlagen lasst es uns gemeinsam
herausfinden viel spaß mit dieser folge
von rolex trader das würde bedeuten dass
diese folge potenziell die letzte vor
der rolex wird was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge rolex trade up es geht endlich
weiter gingen letzte woche schon weiter
aber es geht diese woche auch wieder
weiter wenn ich das video gefällt mir
gerne like da vergesse nicht den kanal
zu abonnieren damit ihr kein video mehr
verpasst jetzt viel spaß mit dem video
als allererstes müssen wir natürlich
schauen wo wir die seiner passion
herbekommen jeder will günstig an die
teuren klamotten rankommen und daraus
jetzt noch profit zu schlagen wird nicht
ganz einfach wir starten damit im
internet nach günstigen designer
klamotten zu suchen auch in den letzten
folgen habe ich mich in territorien
vorgewagt wo ich relativ wenig ahnung
habe und es hat trotzdem funktioniert so
kann es dieses mal auch wieder sein wenn
wir nur richtig danach suchen
ach ja außerdem ich habe in dem experten
gesprochen wegen der grip bewährung ich
wollte ja eigentlich eine erstellen die
ich dann wirklich verkaufen kann mit
wirklichen nutzen
er hat mir absolut davon abgeraten weil
die deutsche finanzaufsicht morgen sonst
bei mir klopft und sagt oder was
verkaufst du da deswegen werde ich das
sein lassen aber genau während ihr
dieses video essay band das am sonntag
lebt wenn ich live und habe mir etwas
anderes überlegt wo ihr teil von sein
könnte und wo wir auch was eine krippe
gemeinsam macht also checkt die linke in
der video beschreibung kommt auftritt
und wir machen gemeinsam ein bisschen
trip programm
sehern ein designer fashionszene wenn
das irgendwas bringt ist wahrscheinlich
am meisten gesuchte begriff von den
jugendlichen 2021 könnte mir vorstellen
dass man mit taschen am meisten geld
verdient haben und man man die irgendwo
günstig ist schließt nach es ist so wir
haben gesucht und gesucht und konnten
rein gar nichts finden wir brauchten
also eine andere option und haben
deshalb ein bisschen rum telefoniert
kannst du mir sagen wie es günstig an
designer fashion komme kannst du mir
sagen wo ich günstige designer fashion
bekommen die ich sehen kann
[Musik]
das wahrscheinlich das einzige wo ich
sachen finde die mich jeder findet der
ja das komplett krank ich danke dir da
ist prada da sind werden von denen wir
sachen weiterverkaufen können wenn die
gerade eine lieferung bekommen und wir
eine zwei taschen die richtige banker
sind für einen guten preis und loskommen
[Musik]
gesagt getan eine stunde später wir sind
in roermond und jetzt heißt es sachen
finden die wir für mehr geld verkaufen
können
[Musik]
das gute ist wir können auf dem handy
direkt checken ob irgendwas online für
mehr verkauft wird
die beste idee ich kaufe die sachen
nicht direkt sondern ich fotografiere
sachen die interessant sind stellen die
direkt online und gucke ob ich die in
dem zeitraum wo wir hier sind verkauft
bekommen und kaufte die nur wenn ich die
verkauft bekommen
das ist komplett krank ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass das was werden kann
ich habe eine liste wir haben werbering
amani die square guccione claire rada
philipp plein gibt es leute die was
damit anfangen können und versace und
wenn wir gar nichts finden sollten dann
gehen wir einfach auf north face k hat
lieber ist sachen die immer
funktionieren neben dach ein passant mit
und dann klappt das essay für staaten
direkt mit meinem absoluten highlight
ich glaube dass wir die hilfe chance
haben sachen zu kaufen die betreiber
verkaufen können und das ist ja ich gehe
auch davon aus dass wir uns auch
ziemlich lange anstellen müssen und ob
wir dann da sachen finden bei denen es
wirklich möglich ist keine ahnung ich
habe auf jeden fall schon von leuten
gehört die taschen gekauft haben die
institute 500 euro mehr verkauft haben
aber wir werden sehen und wir müssen
gucken was sie gerade waren tatsächlich
war es dort viel größer als ich gedacht
hätte und ich habe echt eine menge zeit
gebraucht um uns von vorne nach hinten
einmal komplett durchzuarbeiten
die haben nicht nur die männer sachen
geguckt haben die frauen sachen geguckt
werden alles einmal abgecheckt
abfotografiert mit preisen im internet
verglichen und freunde gefragt die ein
bisschen mehr ahnung von dem ganzen
thema haben und schlussendlich haben uns
aufgrund von diesen informationen für
folgende dieses match wir haben ein
portemonnaie eine shopping bag eine
bleibt übernahme auch als umhängetasche
tragen kann und ich entscheide mich
gerade noch erwischen damit nehmen wir
haben jetzt schon viele produkte
komplett krank sind
weil dieser durch die fotos die ins tor
gemacht hatte hatte ich die möglichkeit
die sachen sofort online zu stellen
nicht nur bei ebay kleinanzeigen und
wind sondern tatsächlich auch bei steel
mit fabrik ein secondhand shop mit
passender instagram seite den ich
erstellt habe um mystery boxen zu
verkaufen der war aber ganz nützlich um
auch hier diese designer sachen zu
verkaufen er ist wirklich unglaublich
wir sind circa 10 minuten aus dem kader
store aus und aus dieser tasche von den
drei sachen die ich gekauft habe
haben wir das portemonnaie sofort mit 95
euro profit verkauft jetzt direkt
nochmal zu dem prada laden und kauft das
selbe portemonnaie noch mal das fühlt
sich an wie gta manier blitz ich habe in
die story dieses bild hier gepostet ich
habe das in dem kaders tor gemacht und
sofort können
euro profit verkauf unglaublich
wahrscheinlich wird prada das beste sein
was wir heute erleben voll motiviert
durch den ersten verkauf haben wir
angefangen die anderen designer stores
abzuklappern und wurde sofort enttäuscht
wir durften nicht filmen die schlangen
waren zu lang und haben absolut nur
scheiße ich habe doch noch alle sachen
gekauft gegen die ich mich beim ersten
mal entschieden habe wir haben noch zwei
sonnen drin und nochmal genau dass er
gekommen ohne gekauft weil wir das erste
innerhalb von zehn minuten verkauft
haben fühle ich mich ziemlich konnte
denn wenn es einmal können kann wissen
zweites mal die sonnenbrillen zu 136
profit kriege ich die safety act und
jetzt haben wir drei tüten voll mit
rasta weil uns die anderen designer
stores so krank enttäuscht haben haben
wir dann angefangen ein paar mehr basic
stores abzuklappern north face k hat und
wie sie alle heißen leider wurden wir
dort auch nicht fündig und haben uns auf
dem weg zurück nach köln
zurück in deutschland kann ich euch
endlich die ganzen sachen zeigen die wir
von diversesten designern wir haben nur
sachen von prada gekauft kann ich euch
alle sachen zeigt mir nur von prada
gekauft haben auch gut
diese brille in weiß und ich finde es ja
ich finde auch sehr gut brille nummer
zwei genau dasselbe nochmal in schwarz
wunderbar diese nummer drei eine
wunderbare kleine tasche und wenn man
sehr motiviert wäre könnte man die auch
um die schulter traf exakt easy peasy
kneist für 120 ein sehr guter die für
genau 200 euro in dieser wunderbaren
tasche befindet sich eine rader shopping
bags erklingt eins der besten teams ist
für uns kurz und gut das lied das wir
direkt verkaufen konnten sämtliche
strada portemonnaie mit geld klemme in
der mitte denn wie wir alle wissen haben
wir diverse scheine in bar die wir immer
dabei haben müssen haben wir aber schon
verkauft für 300 euro mit 95 euro profit
und das allerletzte thies das kies das
am meisten geld gekostet hat und was mir
am besten gefällt wo ich auch wirklich
wirklich am überlegen ob ich das nicht
aus dem projekt raus kaufe eine baby
blaue klatsch cross beck wie auch immer
für diese tasche 570 euro gezahlt und da
bin ich gespannt ob wir jemanden finden
denn mehr dafür bezahlt jetzt heißt es
käufer finden die sachen überall
einstellen und hoffentlich eine menge
geld verdienen und ich glaube dass es
mit diesem produkt und wirklich kein
problem sein sollte oder vielleicht doch
ich wollte gerade anfangen damit preise
für die ganzen produkte rauszusuchen und
wenn ich nicht komplett falsch liege
dann kostet die shopping bag die ich für
zwei jahren gekauft habt auf der partner
website 1100 euro ich werde probieren
sie mal für irgendeinen absurden preisen
vergleich zu den 200 euro einkaufspreis
einzustellen und dann schauen wir ob
daraus irgendwas werden kann
aber das wäre komplett krank weil das
würde bedeuten dass diese folge
potenziell die letzte vor der rolex wird
designerklamotten und designerklamotten
preise brauchen auch die seiner fotos
deswegen haben uns da wieder nicht
lumpen lassen ihr wisst des fotos
verkaufen wir haben uns eine menge mühe
und haben die fotos nach bestem wissen
und gewissen gemacht um möglichst teuer
zu verkaufen
die anzeigen sind gerade mal fünf
minuten online und wir haben schon die
ersten interessenten zum einen
irgendwelche bot die wollen dass ich die
sachen ins ausland schicke das kennt man
ja von ebay kleinanzeigen und zum
anderen haben wir ein interessent für
die größte tasche was zum einen sehr gut
und zum anderen sehr schlecht ist weil
ich die eigentlich selber behalten
möchte und aus diesem projekt raus
kaufen will
ich werde jetzt hier weiter verhandeln
wir schauen ob vielleicht noch andere
leute interesse an den anderen produkten
haben außerdem haben wir schon zuschauer
geschrieben dass ich dort bitte viel
spaß bei diesem projekt haben soll dass
sie gerne was kaufen würden wenn sie
mehr geld hätten aber das geld einfach
nicht reicht vielen dank dafür grüße
gäben raus probier jetzt die sachen zu
verkaufen und wenn die größte berg
wirklich an dem punkt angekommen ist
dass jemand sie wirklich kaufen durch da
muss ich mir noch mal genau überlegen ob
ich die selber aus dem projekt raus
kaufe oder ob ich sie verkauft es ist
soweit ich habe mich mit dem käufer
geeinigt 680 euro all-in hätte ich für
die blaue tasche bekommen wunderbarer
preis damit hätten wir sowieso viel
profit gemacht ich weiß nicht mehr genau
dafür wie viel wie sie gekauft haben ich
habe mich aber tatsächlich dafür
entschieden sie aus dem projekt
rauszukaufen weil sie mir zu gut gefällt
trotzdem werde ich dem profit eintragen
weil ich dann selber in dieses projekt
reingehe
ich hätte sie für den preis verkaufen
können nehme sie jetzt aber doch lieber
selber der erste tag lief gut aber wir
hatten immer noch eine menge produkte zu
verkaufen und alles hing also am zweiten
und letzten verkaufstag wie soll das bei
rolex trade up auch anders sein tag
nummer zwei es läuft gar nix ich habe
mit mehreren leuten geschrieben es gibt
ein paar leute die wirklich interesse
haben aber es kommt einfach nicht zu
einem kauf ich weiß nicht was machen
soll ich könnte jetzt wieder ein webshop
bau und werbung schalten aber die
gewinne sind tatsächlich deutlich
kleiner als ich gedacht hätte die
produkte kosten zwar an sich relativ
viel geld aber wir haben eben auch viel
dafür ausgegeben also die gewinnmarge
ist relativ niedrig und irgendwie kriege
ich niemanden dazu die produkte im
endeffekt wirklich zu kaufen wir haben
vier interessenten für die große
shopping bag wir haben zwei
interessenten für die kleine tasche wir
haben einen interessenten für eine
sonnenbrille wir haben eine menge
interessenten die jetzt schon
abgesprungen sind die aber grundsätzlich
interesse gehabt hätten keine ahnung was
machen soll ich glaube ich kann einfach
nur sitzen und war sie hat vielleicht
gleich nochmal ein paar facebook-gruppen
abklappern in denen high fashion sachen
oder in den allgemeinen mode thema ist
aber an und für sich schwieriger als
gedacht und der letzte tag wie zu
erwarten ernüchternd ich habe gerade
noch mal mit übels vielen leuten
und her geschrieben ist es zu keinem
kauf gekommen und wir müssen diese folge
mit einem negativbetrag beenden es ist
eine schande aber wir können über die
nächste zeit während ich die nächsten
videos weiter produzieren lasse ich die
berater sache natürlich online und wie
die weiterzuverkaufen
es ist jetzt nicht fest - aber es ist
schon traurig die folge nicht mit plus
beendet zu haben
ich hoffe trotzdem sie hat euch gefallen
wenn ja lass mir gerne an leica vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder und
ich hoffe ihr lasst es euch gut gehen